let's bring in Dave Roberts the Dodgers
manager he joins us on the program what
do you want to talk about today Dave Dan
it's good to have thanks for having me
on I want to talk about the 2020 Dodgers
okay let's talk 2020 Dodgers all right
so you'll win the World Series
if what one thing if we get better every
day I know that's vague but I like your
I like your question all right let's go
talk about the Astros now got it how do
you how do you get your team to I know
that everybody's angry and once a piece
of meat you know they want there but you
know do justice here but how do you keep
your team kind of focused on moving
forward to 2020 actually I don't think
that's difficult I think that you know
people are sounding off but I think that
in within our organization
we get we just had our first day of
pitchers and catchers full squad
workouts so all guys are talking about
is getting ready for this season did
Magic Johnson just walk in magic is in
Chicago he's on the phone and he might
make a trip out to Glendale at some
points we're trying to get him out here
to Arizona oh he's on a conference call
there that you've got some good Intel
man very good this is real time stuff
well I heard somebody say hi magic so
I'm assuming that you don't have anybody
on your team named magic no that wore
number 32 pointer turn show time you
know it's on the phone we're trying to
get them here yeah as far as Cody
Bellinger's comments Justin Turner what
do you do as a manager there in a
situation like like that that they want
to express their opinions but what do
you say to them well I think that it's
expressing your opinions your thoughts
and after that then you move forward so
I think that those guys aren't positive
thoughts and opinions and they were
voiced and
ready to move forward what did you sense
in 2017 when you when you faced the
Astros anything in particular no just
just a really evenly matched ballclub
and very talented did you ever
it feels like every team has a guy who
is trying to get an edge in steal signs
but not do it with surveillance or
cameras there did the Dodgers have that
guy who is looking at the third-base
coach or trying to sneak a peek at the
catcher we have a lot of guys that are
always trying to get that on field
advantage and I think that that's that's
kind of baseball and that's the fun
thing that kind of you know behind the
curtain stuff that that draws people in
the thinking part of the game so we have
actually a lot of guys like that when
you were at second base now you're
playing days you're looking in what what
can you see and then what can you convey
did you ever do that or have somebody do
that for you absolutely and that's
baseball Dan right and they have a fun
part that's the fun part about it and
you know when you get pitchers that can
kind of change things up and kind of
keep you on your toes and keep you
guests and that that's the fun part
that's the game within the game but how
do you send that message to the hitter
just you know subtle moves that's like
whether it's the helmet it's the front
foot it's a right foot first it's the
look one way there's a lot of different
things and every team has different ways
to kind of relay talking to Dave Roberts
by the way his red stitch wine it the
cab is spectacular
you liked it yes yeah you you've done a
great job that's basically me me asking
for more red wine okay done is this on
its way no it's that red stitch wine
that you came up with I think you guys
started like 2007 but I don't think
you've had a batch that's been under 90
as far as the rating there so it has an
as what one day we're gonna get together
we're gonna do a little vertical tasting
how about that DP I'm okay with that
I'm good with that give me the like
what's Joc Peterson's future there with
the Dodgers Jaques in a great place and
obviously I think to be honest with you
Dan I think that people made more of it
as far as Jaques men
frame and where he's at he couldn't be
more excited to be back with us to get
to work with his teammates this will
help this team win baseball game so it's
part of baseball and I know personally
I'm happy to have him with us but yeah I
think a lot was made of it but as far as
him and Ross they're both in a good
place but you know we're Andrews you
know the front office are always working
to make our club better and where we're
at right now I love the guys we have in
our Clubhouse who has a better chance of
having a plate appearance during the
regular season for the Dodgers joc
pederson or me you know what that's a
tough question dance I'm jock has a
better chance to play defense for the
Dodgers no [ __ ] I just wanted to make
sure and I like your your your care and
your company but I'm gonna go ja Mookie
Betts coming there what role is is he
gonna bat leadoff where's he gonna be in
the lineup there for you yeah he'll hit
at the top and and Mookie you know we're
still learning him and trying to get to
know each other but obviously the track
record the baseball card speaks for
itself and I just think that that is
really important but I think that what
he does for the loss and organization
and the city itself the fan base that
infusion of talent and character is big
for us and I think that a lot of people
were all going to be gravitating towards
him and he's going to make us win a lot
of baseball games and yeah I see him in
right field and at the top of the order
what about David prices role in that
rotation David is going to be in the
middle of rotation and he's a guy that
battled injury last year and he's a
former side young winner he's a team guy
team first guy and there's a lot of
gratitude there's a lot of compete I we
expect him to have a great year this
this year and kind of help anchor this
rotation can you have any more pressure
on you Dave considering what's happened
in the last couple of years and now you
add Mookie Betts to that lineup and
David Price no I I don't think that you
can look at it as more pressure damn you
know I think that if you look at a goal
changing or expectations expectations
changing I think that that's that'd be a
question but for us
winning the World Series hasn't changed
so our rosters changed but the goal
remains the same and we've added some
really good players and now it's just up
to us to go out there and play good
baseball put ourselves in the position
to do that
and win 11 games in October final
question who do you consider the 2017
world champs so you had to go there
right I have to as much as I like you I
have to end what 2017 is in the past
we're I want to be the 2020 champions
world series champions so you know
that's that's all I can say I mean
honestly Dan I'm thrilled about the 2020
Dodgers it has to bother you it bothers
me Dave I have to ask you that question
I mean it I love the way Dan that you're
our voice you're my voice and I think
that the Dodger fans fans in general
voicing their opinions that's a good
thing for baseball and it shows how much
they care about not only the Dodgers
baseball itself this this fan interest
that's good for all of us and so you
being my voice Dan that's great why
don't you guys hold a parade
we that's a question for Stan casting so
I'm just focused on the guys in
clubhouse great Stan and Mark Walter I
think your first home Stan you just have
a victory parade just just outside the
stadium there have a have a couple of
trombones and we're gonna have a parade
this year how about that one are you are
you guaranteeing that parade I'm gonna
guarantee we're gonna do everything we
are you look at you look at you look at
you very Pro hey thanks Dave
alright Dan take care that's Dave
Roberts Dodger manager for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]